Let's take a second to think about the past couple of quizzes you've done. We
saw that a vertical line, reflected in the line y equals x, becomes a
horizontal line. Now, just like we have the vertical line test to determine if
graphs are functions, remember, it says that a given curve is a function if it
only crosses a vertical line at one point for each value of x in the domain. We
can perform another test on the graph to figure out if its reflection in the
line, y equals x would be a function. That would mean that it has an inverse.
Which of these statements do you think is true, then? A function has an inverse
if no horizontal line passes through its graph at more than one point. A
function has an inverse if no vertical line passes through its graph at more
than one point. A function has an inverse if all horizontal lines pass through
its graph at more than one point. Or, a function has an inverse if the line, y
equals x, passes through its graph at more than one point. Think back to the
vertical line test, and how functions are related to their inverses.